dr
sadler we hope that you provide us some
clarity about your research
the process of it and we thank you for
coming to talk with us today about it
so please welcome dr sadler today
thanks so i'm actually very excited to
talk in national library week about this
because the story of my book
is in some part story a library
and what happened in that library for me
and sort of research that
took place
so a little bit of history about these
debates this is this presentation i'm
not going to be
trying to go you know very deep into
that they start in about 1931
and they uh take place
originally starting in paris with the
society francis de philosophy there's a
session
which is specifically on the issue of
christian philosophy
is there is there such a thing is it
possible if
if there is such a thing what would its
nature be how would we know
how to distinguish it from non-christian
philosophy and
some of the very important intellectuals
at that time
get invited to this this is sort of the
who's who of philosophy
in 1930s france and they hash the issues
out and these are people who actually
knew each other for a long time
some of them had studied with each other
and
had written in response to each other so
it's not something completely new it's
not as if somebody just threw it on the
table and said
christian philosophy what about that and
then people lined up there were already
some
some lines drawn about this um
the battle lines actually start getting
drawn and interestingly
the first battle lines are between
secularists what we would nowadays call
secularist
philosophers but they were called
rationalists at that time
and um various christian philosophers
most of whom were catholic there were
some french reformed
protestant philosophers who got involved
in the debate as well
but then very quickly the catholic
philosophers start having an
intra-catholic debate with each other
some of them actually are against the
notion of christian philosophy they say
philosophy and theology have to be kept
completely distinct
others say well no there is such a thing
and you can find it in history
others say well it would be a project
yet to be worked out
and so they're arguing with each other
sometimes understanding each other well
sometimes not
you know grasping with each other or
after
and they engage each other through
literary means
part of it is face to face through is it
working
part of it is face to face through
conferences there's three main
conferences in which this takes place
the society frances the philosophy in
1931
and then in 1932 the society detude
philosophy
meets and they discussed the issue and
then i've actually brought some uh some
props you might say um in 1933 the
society thomas the
whole mystic philosophers they decide to
make their second day of study devoted
to the problem of christian philosophy
and they
they bring together people who are for
it and people who are against it and
they hash it out
in those debates and i've got i've run
along a number of different
texts that you can you can take a look
at if you want um
i i hardly need to say any of this too
because many of your librarians have to
be handled with some care because
they're very old and you notice that
i've i've given them quite a beating
myself
as i've read through them interestingly
i think all of you know this french
books um that were written
and published back then they all more or
less look the same don't they they all
have the same
kind of uh look to them and they're well
constructed
they hold together pretty pretty well
don't they compared to some
english and american ones okay so
there's a digression
they start writing articles in a number
of different journals
some of these are major philosophical
journals some of them are are
devoted to church history some of them
are devoted to history itself some of
them
are devoted to theology they write some
books
atn jill sohn comes along and the
year after that he does the gifford
lectures and he publishes these they've
been translated as the
spirit of medieval philosophy
maurice blondel publishes the philosophy
jacques moratan publishes a book which i
believe we have in the library here
an essay on christian philosophy and a
number of people are engaged in this
they're all writing
in response to each other they're not
just going off on their own
they are interlocutors in a vast debate
so about 50 or so authors get involved
some of them more than others
by about 1936 and by 1936
the debates are pretty much over you
start seeing articles where they're
summarizing the debates
rather than trying to make any new
contributions so that's a sign that
we're pretty much done
would it have continued on perhaps but
all of you know
what's taking place in history at this
time the build up to world war
ii so they're becoming very preoccupied
with other issues and the major
philosophers are moving on to different
issues
um i call this a rogues gallery or a
who's who
you know depending on which side you you
fit in on this and i just want to talk
about a few of the
major uh figures who are involved at
whose archives are at the university of
toronto
he was a major player he was actually
one of the people who was invited to
speak
at that very first associate de frances
the philosophy meeting that was
his presentation that in effect gets the
ball rolling
uh his good friend jacques martin
another french thomas philosopher
etienne joseon was a major historian in
philosophy he was one of the guys
who sort of brought medieval philosophy
back into
the french philosophical uh educational
establishment because until then they
they had the
sort of enlightenment ideal that well
the middle ages they were just dark ages
there was nothing worthwhile to study
nothing to look at
and joseon was one of the people who
pioneered that he wasn't the first
person to actually teach medieval
philosophy
in france he sometimes gets gets
credited for that but he actually wasn't
the first it was another guy
who was involved in these debates
mauritan his
his archives are actually at the
university of notre dame in indiana
another major catholic philosopher
contributes a lot to our understanding
of the debates
again he and jill sohn saw eye to eye on
these things they can they constituted
the core of one
major sign maurice blondell i found a
nice painting of him
online this is probably about what he
looked like at the time of the debates
he was somewhat older than jill song
and mauritan they were in a different
generation
interestingly he had studied with some
of the same people and he had some of
the same life path he was another
major catholic philosopher whose
book oxyom it's been translated by
olive oblashette who recently actually
just brought out another book on blondel
excellent book
that i would recommend for anybody
studying these things
this was a very revolutionary stuff
this this transformed philosophical
discourse and
as mrs whitfield was saying
some of this actually believe it or not
led to the second vatican council
maurice blondel's thought
through several different strains leads
to to that very important event in
20th century theology philosophy
the blown down articulates a whole new
position
leon brunchfig who kind of looks a bit
like bondell on this one doesn't he
um leon brunchfig was on the other side
he was against christian philosophy he
was what we would call today a
secularist
when you hear people like you know
richard dawkins or christopher hitchens
these people who are very big
in the the media right now and create a
big splash he was
one of those of the day and so he was
arguing against the possibility of
christian philosophy
um he was helped out by
the very young emile brennier uh who
had recently made a big splash by giving
some conferences where he argued there
was no such thing as christian
philosophy
anything that could even remotely look
like that was not real philosophy
um because it wasn't real thought it was
constrained by religious law
we don't have a picture of him i went
online to try to find pictures of these
guys
you can't find a picture of the neil
brenier anywhere i'm not quite sure why
but that's the case so i put up a
picture of one of his books
gabriel marcel a french existentialist
philosopher and phenomenologist he was
one of the people who argued for the
possibility of christian philosophy and
he articulated yet another
position land noel
was a good example of a neotomist
who argued against the possibility of
christian philosophy i tried to find
somebody else who was even more
important in that fairness on steinberg
but i couldn't find a picture of him
either nor can i find a picture of quite
a few of these guys
finally finally uh andre dulubach one of
the important theologians of the 20th
century
who's influenced a lot of
thinkers both in catholic church and in
protestant churches
he is the guy who in some respects
brings the debates to a close
he writes an article in 1936 called on
christian philosophy
and in it he summarizes everybody's
views and he brings them together and he
says well
you know this this view is compatible
with this and uh but but if you read
through his article it's effectively
bringing the the end to it it's closing
the book it's closing the
chat so those those are some of the main
people involved um a little bit of
intellectual
history some cultural background which
explains
why um people might actually be
interested in in this book today we are
in a situation
as far as the life of the mind goes that
is somewhat similar to that of france
in the early 20th century
so these debates are actually more
timely now
than they were for uh american you know
philosophers and historians and
theologians and even ordinary uh you
know
interested educated literate people
they're more relevant today than they
were perhaps back then
the french third republic was very
secular
um as a matter of fact they they were
so anti-catholics so
obsessed with the notion of separating
church and state
that maurice blondel when he uh attained
his um
his license to teach he was not allowed
to teach for two years
everything was centralized in paris and
the guy who was in charge said well you
brought in religion into your philosophy
i can't allow you in the classroom
now this was in a university this wasn't
just teaching high school
or something like that where you know it
might be
impressionable young minds this was in
the university where it's supposed to be
open
all sides are supposed to be represented
it gives you an idea of what was going
on at that time
philosophy why was philosophy important
well philosophy was viewed as being sort
of the
the king of the disciplines it was the
discipline
which brought together the other ones it
was
the discipline where you would deal with
objects
unconstrained by a single emphasis on
say biology or psychology you're trying
to bring things together in a
comprehensive view
which which has its you know downside
sometimes as well right sometimes it can
get a little
abstract but philosophy was viewed as
one of the central disciplines for
the development of modern thought and
there was a great danger
with that of philosophy sort of losing
sight of its essence and that is
actually
what has happened in large part in
american philosophy
if you know anything about what happened
in the 20th century to american
philosophy
we just at one time have our own
philosophical tradition
and it was in communication with
literature
and the sciences and religion and it was
very broad and it engaged a lot of
things it was sort of like the
philosophy that we're talking about here
analytic philosophy which does have its
you know it's good points but analytic
philosophy came
and with its very narrow emphasis on
you know very specific problems and not
looking at history
not reading texts just only looking at
isolated passages and arguments
it displaced our classical tradition
which was engaged with with these french
thinkers william james and blondel
actually knew each other
so did william james and bertson and
these thinkers communicated back and
forth
they were in danger of the same thing
happening in france when philosophy
tries to purify itself and become very
you know methodologically astute usually
the result is
it quits being philosophy you know it's
one of those sort of things where
the more you try to fix it and and you
know just clean it up and we're only
going to do this
the less philosophical you are and so
there was a great danger
and this was being pointed out during
the debates um
at the same time this is very
interesting
religious thought was undergoing a
renaissance in france
and it had been since about the 1860s
previously to that or prior to that
sorry if you had looked at
say french catholic and even even
protestant thoughts say in 1830
or 1800 it was pretty morbid
it was it was pretty dull
kind of clueless stuff you know a lot of
preaching to the choir
not a lot of engagement of other
perspectives
not a lot of what you could call first
class thinkers
in the early part of the 20th century
there's this massive awakening that
takes place and it may take
it may take place in part because of the
pressure exerted on them
from the secular establishment you know
when you have to undergo
diversity like that sometimes that
brings out the best doesn't it when you
have to engage your interlockers and you
can't just sort of sit back on your
laurels
but there were a lot of things going on
and so you had some first
class serious you know
contenders for being you know the major
philosophers out there and they were
they were religious so you could
actually have a debate though about
christian philosophy because you have
people out there not just talking about
it
but perhaps even modeling it
um also what was going on too is people
were doing better history
again like i pointed out there was this
perception for a long time that the
middle ages were just dark ages
and if you don't read medieval thinkers
that's really easy to
uh to agree with isn't it and that is
still what we teach in some of our
our high school and even some of our
college history classes
in my critical thinking classes
sometimes i will bring up
with my students in the middle ages did
everyone think the world was
was round or flat and they all say flat
well if you actually read somebody like
anselm of canterbury
in one of his books he says he just
mentions this offhand well as we all
know the world is around
he's writing to educated people of his
time this is not in the high middle ages
this is actually before
around the time of the norm of conquest
but educated people at that time knew
that so why don't we
from the from the vantage point to the
present
know that quite often well because
people have done
poor history they've done ideologically
based history
so what was going on with this
people like jill sohn were in fact
doing better and better history and he
and brettier actually clashed about
the the historical connections there so
that made it into a live issue
um why was it you know philosophy of
christianity
one really quick answer to that is that
france is you know not a buddhist nation
it was not a hindu nation it was a a
christian nation
at least you know demographically
but there were some historical issues i
mean if you look at the history of
philosophy there were christian
philosophers
so is the sort of thing that they were
doing is that still
philosophy if they allowed their their
christian faith to
become very important is thomas aquinas
a philosopher or is he just a theologian
he is anselm of canterbury you know
comes up with the so-called ontological
argument
is that just theology or is that
philosophy we teach it in intro to
philosophy class but
maybe we shouldn't be if that's not the
case
philosophy takes on different emphases
in different times
in the middle ages it took on you know a
lot of issues about the nature of god
or the way society ought to be organized
um there's some other interesting things
going on the modern era is not just
a time of secularization it's a time
when people are pushing
secularization when they're saying this
is a good thing you ought to be getting
rid of religion
religion is just you know irrational we
need to push it off the scene
and we need to push off the modes of
thought that we're focusing on that so
if you have that sort of viewpoint then
you get rid of thomas appointments you
get rid of blaze pascal
you get rid of maurice bloemdel too
philosophy and religion are bound to
come into some sort of contact with each
other too because think about it when a
person has a philosophy what do we mean
by that
means that they have some sort of
overarching
you know tie everything together view
from uh you know a sort of synthetic
perspective
of everything if they really have a
philosophy
that's what it means what is it if
somebody really has religious faith
something like that too isn't it if
somebody really is committed
that it pervades the entirety of their
life
now if they happen to be somebody who's
living the life of the mind
the religious faith will somewhat
pervade that won't it
inevitably so the question is is that a
good thing or is that a bad thing
does that mean that they can't really be
a historian
a philosopher a
psychologist does that interfere with it
or does it actually in some respects
make it better that's that's a live
issue that these people were debating
about
by 1930 a lot of people have been using
this term christian philosophy but
nobody had actually defined it
so what happens when people use terms
in a lot of different ways with a lot of
different meanings pretty soon somebody
starts saying hey we better figure out
what we actually mean by this do you
mean this
or this or this and that's part of what
they were trying to do
in these debates now
that's all background now i'd like to
tell you a little bit of the story this
is where we get to the library matters
i'd like to tell you a little bit of the
story
of how i got involved in this and so it
becomes a little bit more
idiosyncratic a little bit more
narrative at this point because i'm not
a big philosopher
i'm i'm just somebody who likes this
stuff
so i went to graduate school like like
you know most philosophy pros do and
i actually did my dissertation on
maurice blomdell i never published it
because it wasn't
in my view anything that could be
published and
it really needs to be broken down into
several different works i you know i did
some interesting things but it was kind
of incoherent
and then like a lot of people what i did
is i put it aside
you know after you finish those of you
you know done master's theses or
dissertations what's the first thing you
want to do after you get done with it
something else put it aside and don't
think about it but i did still really
like maurice blondell
and a colleague of mine uh adrian pabst
who i'd run at i'd run into at a
conference
he was actually studying in paris and he
sent me those these photocopied
documents
and he said you know you like
translating why don't you translate
maurice blondel
translate some of this stuff and those
were a few documents from these debates
and i didn't know about these debates
before that and actually i
let those sit for about six months
before i i picked them up
then when i did and i started reading
through them i started saying there's
really something here there's
some really interesting discussions and
this isn't just maurice blondell
this is at joel sohn jack morten right
here
they all have these different sides
what's going on here so i started
digging a little bit
and like i put here as i started
researching
what i found out two things one was the
english-speaking literature on this
on these debates they called it a debate
they didn't call it debates
and they saw it as just between you know
one or two people or not one or two
two or three people just a few sides
either
eighteen zero psalm versus uh emile
breit and then blown dell had written a
little bit about it
poor um 18 joseon versus von steinbergen
and the reason that that was the case is
because jill's own stuff was translated
um blondel stuff wasn't most of the
other people's stuff wasn't
so what do you know english speaking
english reading
researchers often do they stick to the
stuff that's available in english
and there's a vicious cycle if you don't
read the foreign languages
you have no idea about what's going on
in these other texts and then
you you know have no interest in seeing
them translated
and it keeps reinforcing itself so i
decided i wanted to break this
this cycle and as i did it and i found
more and more texts and this this took
place over a period of about three years
this bigger and bigger and bigger
picture kept emerging
and i started seeing more and more signs
and more and more discussions and i
started finding out that even the
bibliographies of the debates
were not complete that there were
sources there were discussions that were
not in
the bibliographies and i had to track
them down
so i have a metaphor for this it's sort
of like going from
imagine you're in a concert hall
and there's two or three singers out
there and they're singing back and forth
to each other
and then more voices come in and more
voices come in
and it's all very well orchestrated
um eventually it's an entire chorus
and some of them are singing you know
this this line and some are singing this
line
and it's all going back and forth so
you're going from just a few
voices singing a couple melodies to this
gigantic
very involved uh not always harmonious
uh because it was a bit you know it was
there were debates
uh but it was this gigantic course
now the work of translation itself i
enjoy translating and i had done it
before
i translated a few things from french
when i was in graduate school
and i've been a member of the aquinas
translation project translating some of
aquinas's
latin works mostly his commentary on
psalms
back when i was in graduate school and i
continued doing that so
this seemed to be something i could i
could sink my teeth into something i
would like to do
but this was very different
when i translated before it was it was
single things or it was part of a
larger work by one author with this
i was actually deciding to translate
um many works by many different authors
the what i've got in here is
in large part maurice bloemdell but also
at angel song
his part isn't in there um
gabriel marcel all the people who were
talking with blonde elephant steinberg
and all these people have different
voices you know we don't write the same
and it was very exciting to try to
replicate their different tonalities
and to see how their thoughts played off
against each other and the work of
translation
if any of you do it you know it's very
different than say
writing your own work you're giving
voice to another person
and it's very liberating in a way you
don't have to come up with anything
original
which is kind of nice for your academic
you don't have to try to do original
history of philosophy or ideas you just
have to help somebody else
speak in a different language your own
language
and so that is what i did i
i got into it and i found myself
enjoying it i would go down to
my basement office day after day after
day and translate and then go back over
the translations
and i started writing about it and
publishing some articles about it
and talking about it and then what i was
doing at the same time i call this
haunting and prospecting the stats this
is where we get to something we were
discussing before
the presentation why it's so important
to have access to libraries
what i would do is i would actually go
and i would dig through entire
entire journal collections and
i couldn't have done that if they
weren't available if they weren't in the
stacks
and they weren't available in a lot of
libraries i found this out when i had to
get the book you know go through the
entire process of publishing
catholic university of america press
said send us the originals that you're
translating from
i said well i'm sure you have them
you're in washington dc you're a
catholic america catholic university of
america
and they went in their library they
didn't have them and these were very
important french journals
these weren't you know some obscure
thing they just didn't have
a lot of research libraries are not as
well stocked as
some of the ones that i was fortunate
enough maybe spoiled
into thinking we're the norm um
and i would just go and and you know
spend sometimes a
saturday afternoon or i would get off of
work teaching
and then i would drive to the library
and i would wait
you know until nine at night ten at
night and just
go through this set of journals or these
these books
did a lot of digging around and like i
put here it's kind of an academic an
academic form of play it was very
enjoyable
it was like doing something
a cross between a scavenger hunt and
traipsing around in the woods
and that was possible only because those
stacks were open
and because things were well organized
and you could find
what you were looking for
so the work of libraries is very you
know very vital
where did i do all this at notre dame
university i lived about an hour and a
half away
and so i would drive out there it was
not that far
from the prison where i was working at
the time
what would i do i would scour the stacks
and
sometimes i would find only one new
article sometimes i wouldn't even find
any
sometimes i would hit the mother lode
and find you know a book i hadn't known
about or
five articles and i would photocopy all
of them i actually have a file cabinet
filled with these these photocopies
there were several parts of notre dame
hesper library and i've got some nice
shots of it here
because i have a very strong attachment
to that place there were several places
that were
or organizations that were particularly
instrumental i'd like to
tell you a little bit about that notre
dame has a medieval institute
and so a lot of the people who were
doing work on this issue were
medievalists
so i would go there and i would dig
through their materials
they also have the jacques moratan
center and
i found some of my sources there and i
also
found a lot of hospitality from the
people who run the jean martin center
because he was one of the people
involved in these debates and they were
they were very helpful with me and then
i was lucky enough to get a summer
fellowship
to not to study christian philosophy or
the debates
but actually to study practical
rationality
with aleister mcintyre in this this
erasmus institute faculty fellowship
well they put us up at notre dame and
you know they fed us
really great food of course too so what
did i do every night
after we got done with our fellowship
stuff i was in the library for about
four hours
and it was you know this wasn't
something that you could do
once and get it over with it's not get
an ebsco and
download you know a few articles this is
the sort of thing that research requires
and research you know when people say
why do you actually need a library why
do you need all these physical stats
because you actually don't know until
you get in there how much work you're
going to have to do
and so you know i don't know if anybody
who makes those sort of decisions will
see this but
i would love for them to hear about this
sort of thing and
how important it is just to have
resources in place for those who
want to use them here's a few other
images from from notre dame
yeah here's the stacks these are
actually the basement ones where some of
the
popular journals were kept and i had to
go through the popular journals as well
because this was
a an issue that people were talking
about so people would write about it in
some of the french newspapers
um this is uh an interesting image does
anyone know
what what this one is there's kind of a
story about the notre dame ashford
library
i always thought it was touchdown it is
and you can see it from
the notre dame coliseum it's it's you
know i don't think they originally
meant it to be uh jesus giving the
touchdown thing
it's this vast mosaic and it's the
signature piece you know there's the
apostles and
and the kings and all all these other
people but yeah
apparently if you get in the stadium you
can see jesus getting the touchdown
inside
so um
now what what's in the book what what do
readers get from it
this is actually the very beginning of
my book tour so
i have to give you a kind of a pitch
right um
there's translations of a lot of
documents and
some of these are from key moments in
the debates i translated
jill sohn's um piece
at the associated front says philosophy
because that is one of the central
pieces hadn't been translated
we got the permission from the jillson
archives and and uh it's in there
maurice blondel's works his voice had
been allowed to go silent
because again nobody had translated it
so everyone assumed it wasn't important
there wasn't anything going on there
nobody looked at it and then of course
nobody translated it and i i wanted to
break that cycle
representative pictures of main
positions i i've got some of the
some of the catholic thomists who were
actually against
christian philosophy represented in
there as well
i've got some of the the rationalists
who were against christian philosophy
and that important commentary there were
there were some people whose commentary
kind of defined the debate they weren't
you know key players themselves but they
provided some really good sum up of what
was going on
and that's kind of a contribution
sometimes just being able to give a good
overview as a contribution and then uh
so that's actually not my own writing
other than you know i translated it
that's everybody else's writing and
that's the bulk of the book
so in a larger respect i'm not really
the author
i list me as the translator and editor
i am the author of one thing the
introduction and there's about 100 page
introduction part of it is historical
giving you you know the background and
what was going on
and then part of it is thematic i do
some studies of the particular
philosophers and then there's something
that's been missing for a while a
chronological bibliography it's not just
a bibliography
which is would be useful by itself just
have a more or less comprehensive one
but a chronological one that lets you
see date by date how the debates are
developing
you know would be really cool would be
to have some sort of online
interactive one where you could index it
on a figure
or a keyword or something like that but
we don't have anything like that yet
i want to give kind of a pictorial
representation of you know what did we
actually get done with this
because you know i'm not writing in a
vacuum some of this stuff is already out
and if you wanted to study these debates
you know for example um jill sohn's
spirit of medieval philosophy major work
in these debates
it's been around for a long time thank
you thank goodness
um here's what i've
done and i didn't put all the little
things in
my book includes parts of the society
francis de philosophy session
joseon blombell's contributions the
entirety of the associated detailed
philosophy
session were blown down and
six other philosophers talked about
about this and debated it back and forth
and a bunch of smaller pieces what's
available in english right now besides
what i've given
she'll sell spirit of medieval
philosophy another book by him
philosophy and christianity where he
actually this is very interesting
he expanded the discussions to include
protestant philosophers
so he's a catholic philosopher engaging
protestant philosophers
uh more attends essay on christian
philosophy is available
and right here's history of philosophy
is available what's not transit well
lonedell's the whole blend of the
philosophy catholic is not translated
yet
you know this is pretty substantive work
so there's still more more work to be
done in in these debates
the uh society 1933 session hasn't been
translated either
that may be something that we need to do
as well
what is good news the blue box article
was translated a while ago
so a good summary of it that brings it
to a close
has been translated
i have a few future projects and i'm a
little bit short on time so i'm going to
skim through this
very quickly i have two book projects
that i
i'm going to start on after this summer
that i already have some
work done on a little bit one is to
write an actual history of the debates
in intellectual history something that
hasn't been done yet
some people have written a bit about it
but nobody's actually
done the history of ideas work yet
um i want to do some additional
translations
again that involves getting permissions
i i have to actually get permission from
the
uh our the center darshev the maurice
blondel in order to translate this but i
think this should be the next thing
translated
and there's actually a maurice bloombell
translation project which is forming
right now
which may in fact tackle that so i might
be i might not have to do it myself i
might be able to push it off on other
people right wouldn't that be nice
i am putting together additional videos
you notice i'm recording right now
i'm putting together additional videos
that deal not just with my book but with
the issues and the figures and
and the debates themselves i upload them
to
youtube right this great web 2.0
environment to work in
and actually i'm going to be putting
together an interactive website
i'm not going to actually release it
until it looks very good but i've
started working on that
a website devoted to this issue and to
the debates
but it will go beyond the debates also
engage not just catholic thinkers but
but the protestant thinkers who talked
about this
um i have a few website things and i'll
be happy to give these to anybody who
wants them you can get my book actually
i'm going to be selling copies here if
anyone wants
to buy one and i'll write something nice
for you
or you can get it from these various
locations
if you're really interested in this and
you want something in english
that gives you an overview of it my um
internet encyclopedia philosophy entry
goes through these debates and narrates
them it's not
quite as long as the introduction of the
book but it's pretty extensive
and then if you want to see videos or
you know read about the book or
actually i'm going to be doing some
podcasts of reading from the book
eventually
my blog has some spots my my website has
and i have a youtube channel
as well i'm finding it's
it's you know it's a great way to get
other people
uh interested in this and you know
disseminate the word this web 2.0
environment
um i was going to do some readings but i
think instead what i'd what i'd rather
do
is um just take questions because it's
already
118 i know people have places to go
so you can take questions or
you guys can take a look at these if you
want to as well should i pass these
around
is these french books
but yeah does anybody have any uh
questions or
i have a question you said that the
third republic
was very secular yes secularists
but as european governments do they were
playing
musical chairs about every two or three
years
so was any of this debate creeping into
the political debate
no um the political debate
largely turned on you know right versus
left things you know like the workers
versus um
uh you know the bourgeoisie or you know
what to do about the rising power of
germany and all those sorts of things
and and what i'm saying is that the the
secularist setting
it really wasn't political so much as it
was
part of the institutional culture i mean
governments would change
right but those bureaucrats in charge
don't
the entire social um system
and uh the people in charge of the
departments
they stay the same similar to our case
you know
we uh we change out
presidents and and representatives and
people like that every so often but
if once you're in the state department
and you're part of the hierarchy you're
in it
once you're in the department of
education the top person may change
but almost all the other people are
going to stay in place and it's very
hard to
alter institutional culture and the
institutional culture was decidedly
secular
as a matter of fact one of the things
that the catholics started doing
in the educational realm was to
establish their own
um universities institut katjadik
and there's one in paris there's there's
one in
marseille by that time i think
they're spread around there's more now
than there there were back then
but like i said you know blondel a great
example of this
lone dell writes this book box you know
he doesn't actually um start from
religion he argues towards religion
going through philosophy that's enough
to keep him from being able to teach and
when he actually does get to teach
they put him out in the provinces he
can't teach in paris
he has to teach way out in the boonies
so
how long would you say it took you to do
your your research on this
well that's a good question um
if we mean like the whole process from
when i first read the material that
adrian sent me to
publication we're talking about
i would say eight years but i would say
that the majority of the
research in the stacks
that was over about a three to four year
period
and i was going out there probably at
least once or twice a month
and some of the time i wasn't very
productive
you know i was just kind of looking
around but that
that sort of um leisure
i think is very important for research
and again you know it's not possible to
do that unless you have
access to the library
we were talking just earlier about
cutting hours and you know the graduate
students not
having as much access they're the ones
who need it the most
and and so much of real research
is not just having a narrowly focused
problem that you're going to solve and
then you're going to get to
but reading around you know and i would
go
i would often be surprised i would go
into a set of stacks
because i was going to look up this one
bibliographical reference
and then this is what happens in stacks
you all know this you're walking along
and you see something that catches your
eye oh what's that
i'm gonna take this down and then you
start paging through and sometimes
there's nothing
useful in there and sometimes you have a
revelation
whoa this guy actually wrote wrote an
article about christian philosophy this
wasn't in any of the bibliographies
oh and he cites three more people three
more sources i can go check out
again you can't do that unless you have
open stacks
so yeah i actually feel bad for the
people
at universities the really big
universities where they don't have open
stacks
you know especially the european ones
i know i know i was late but um i
apologize
but uh yeah you missed the part where i
told everybody everything about it
okay how did you get so proficient in
french and english
oh um my family is
in origin french canadian and i grew up
with my
mom speaking french to me and my uncle's
you know swearing in french and
people talking french around me and i
didn't you know i just sort of absorbed
that but that's not actually learning
french yet and then
i remember when i was a kid my mom made
me take
a french class in middle school and a
french class in high school
like most kids uh forced to do that sort
of stuff i screwed around and i didn't i
didn't
like it and i resisted it but i did
learn some things on the way
and then when i got into college you
know i could talk with my family
um but i didn't i didn't really have a
very large vocabulary and i couldn't do
literary french
then when i got into college they threw
me into this french language house
because they they knew i spoke french
they wanted to get the program going
and then i kind of liked it and i and i
um
we had you know some native speaker from
toulouse there and she and i got to be
friends and we
chat a lot and then
i just started reading and the more that
you read you know it's just like
anything else
the more that you read the more
vocabulary you pick up
the more you start to grasp the
locutions the less
kind of silly mistakes that you make in
translating because you start to grasp
the larger picture
and by the time that i got to graduate
school i was
pretty proficient in french i'd go on to
france and
go on to come back and met some of my my
family and then you know everybody talk
and
my the french that i speak isn't very
pretty it's not it's not the friendship
parents it's kind of a mix of
canadian french and uh and uh
french french which is different than
you know mexican spanish is to
castilian spanish but
it came in very handy for for this sort
of stuff
um and there are actually some french
words that are very difficult to
translate that that
come in here like uh they have this this
word that they were all using at the
time ante
which you could translate as sort of
complete and comprehensive
or sometimes i just use the the cog
integral
none of those are actually captured
adequately
but what are you going to do you know
when you're translating you've got to
get it across somehow
and sometimes the like they say you know
the best can be the enemy the good
and go after the good that you can you
can get so
that's kind of a rambling answer but
it's okay
but they have um i know that
just like in whatever language there is
there's kind of like a vernacular that
is common and then they have their
scholarly
yeah did that make you kind of strong
well
um this is kind of an interesting point
the french that they were writing the
sort of educated academic
scholarly french that they were writing
is
very classical it's um
it's uh not at all like the like the the
the friendship today
not the people's french but the scholars
french i don't like
translating um things written after
about 1960 because i think french style
has just
gone down downhill because they they
they've got all these sort of
affected things and they're really
getting away from that at that time
they nowadays everybody has to show how
clever they are by making plays on words
and very punchy sentences these guys
wanted
these guys took people like saint
augustine or cicero
people like that as their models and
they wanted to write coherent paragraphs
in which the thoughts were clear
and the french language is actually very
good for that if you use it for that
you can also use it to be you know
totally obscure which is what happens
far too often these days unfortunately
so yeah thank you
i'm so interested when you were talking
about the library
in terms of being just able to walk
through down and scan the shells
did they have any of those materials
digitized or you could
search it differently or is ah um
very little of it i would suspect that
more of it is available now
and i know that at the time that i was
beginning work
the french national library had begun
digitizing
some of their journals and i was able to
get
a very few articles that i i needed
from from them i think their their goal
was to digitize everything
so you know for instance they reviewed a
metaphysical
i'm willing to bet that's available
electronically now all over the place
um i can tell you one thing uh i just
thought of
it's not only important at open stacks
it's also very important to have copy
machines all over the place
so that there's enough of them available
uh so you don't have to wait behind
somebody else if you're going to do this
kind of research because i
i did it through photocopies but there
is something to actually holding
the written page in your hand too and
being able to page through a book
i kind of like that bound volumes too
especially journals
you know same same sort of thing as
going through the stacks and seeing
something at random
that catches your eye you go and you
look up um
you know 1934 the august
edition of this but then you're putting
around you find out that there was
something in december that ties into
that as well
so there's there's a value to
having you know the best of both worlds
would be we have everything digitized
and we have
so you had to both both
try to choose you had the best of both
worlds
yeah digitized and on the shelf
and you were starting this again how
would you do it oh god
so would you just look at the digital
versions
that's a good question um
i've never thought of that i've never
actually thought of how i would start
this again if i were to
because you know i like like so many
other research projects i started off
with doing one thing
and then it expanded and there were i
think there were a lot of mistakes i
made along the way
and tracking things down um
i think it would probably be helpful to
have
digitized things to start with but then
there's there's still no substitute for
getting out there and
pounding the linoleum and
digging through through the stacks and
holding books in your hand
and paging your way through them
you know it could be that
what we need are some local you know a
certain amount of local research
libraries where
we could we could do that sort of thing
with scholars
because they're not available everywhere
and i don't i don't actually know how
much of how much of this is still
available at the notre dame
library i haven't been back there for
several years
they might have gotten rid of some of
that
um how what i know she had these
works by boendale and song
what tell me about how you tracked them
down
and what was it easy or was it hard well
um jillson was pretty easy lonedell
as it turned out some of the stuff is
pretty pretty simple like that um
the uh hold up to the philosophy
catholic i ordered that off eight books
you know um and a lot of blondel stuff
was available in bibliographies i did
find
again going through things like looking
through the international congresses of
philosophy
they have all the accounts blondel
actually had some
some discussions about christian
philosophy in different places that
nobody had put into any bibliographies
and i found them by happenstance
um so that would be something very
difficult right i mean that was
sort of needle and haystack type of
stuff there may be some other
things out there that he actually wrote
about christian philosophy that i didn't
find
because one of the things with blondel
is he he not only wrote
under his name he wrote pseudonym
pseudonymously
one of the things that he would do
sometimes to to boost his side
he would bring out a work and then he
would do a review of that work
under somebody else's name and bring out
some aspects of his thought that he
thought had not been sufficiently
emphasized
it wasn't like he was just fluffing you
know he wasn't saying oh this is the
best thing in the world you got to buy
it or
anything like that he was he was using
that as a means to
address people who were attacking him uh
without
actually bringing himself in for for the
full frontal
fire you know if he was out there he's
kind of clever that way
yeah and he'd been doing that since
since he published um axiom in
1893 that drew a lot of fire
from from different people and he did
the same thing he published under a
couple different names
uh and uh defended his book
and it also sort of created the the idea
that oh there's a whole crowd of
scholars out there supporting
them yeah
i suppose you know what the equivalent
would be in today's thing if you were
you create a website and you're taking
controversial positions
and then you create some other web
personas and you have all of them pile
in and say yeah this is really good this
guy knows what he's talking about
don't fight with him that sort of thing
i'll bet you people do that too
they do yeah i was wondering how did you
get the physical books too
that you have the oh you mean these that
i'm that you're passing around
most of them i actually bought what it
was it was very easy because of our web
environment
you know i bought them through eight
books for the most
matter part fact well all of them except
for
the spirit of medieval philosophy and
and this this copy which i bought
through amazon and then um
thank you um the copy of
oxio that i have over here this was
actually given to me when i defended my
dissertation
uh by my my chair
as a gift and then this book
uh christianism and a philosophy which
is actually translated
my mother bought this one for me
at a bookstore milwaukee used bookstore
and
i had recommended that store to her i
was in graduate school down in southern
illinois at the time she went in
and she called me and she said there's
these books you know by jill soon do you
want them
i said how much are they and she said
you know they're like 10 bucks a piece
and i said that's kind of pricey
i'll leave them there but she bought it
anyway and
so i'm very glad she did yeah so i got
them from
different places most of what i work
from though is actually the photocopies
of
[Music]
different articles so
yeah the books are fixed points
and then the articles are all the
constellation around them
sure
any other questions
well thanks for your attention i'm if
you want to
purchase copies i'm selling them
over there i'd be happy actually to
sign the press release or anything like
that if people want
those sorts of things as well so but
thanks for your attention
and i'm glad you have this opportunity
to talk about this research
and about the functional libraries thank
[Applause]
you
you